here's will far forget about the
entertainment world isn't it isn't it
just
time isn't it just time for women to run
the planet I I
mean I'm I'm s I'm not just trying to
Plate you I
swear but I don't know what else to do
because
we men uh we've been running the show
since what 10,000 BC something like
that and we're not doing so good so
so please can you guys just take over
now I understand this is mostly just the
typical Hollywood girl power stick I
also realized that this is coming from
will Ferell who's not exactly known for
his wisdom or
Insight still it's worth pointing out
that everything he said there which is
the kind of thing you hear all the time
these days is absolute nonsense